[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Music]
all righty ladies and gentlemen welcome
to the creek in the cave
just a couple things before we get
started we gotta say you keep your cell
phones away table talk to a minimum and
no heckling but without further ado give
it up start clapping for your house this
evening homeschool
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys good to be here my name
is hans kim i'm an expert dater i've
been on over 15 dates in my lifetime
so i know a thing or two about the
process and it's good to be here
shepherding
the
the dates that are happening is going to
be
very tintillating
i can't wait to see
beautiful relationships be formed
my name is hans kim uh i'm killed tony
regular i had sex in a broom closet once
uh
are you guys ready for your guest
your guest is a very funny comedian she
runs for lipstick comedy please give it
up for bianca parado
[Applause]
she brought popcorn we're gonna watch
you guys
on a date like it's a movie oh yeah this
is gonna get it's gonna get steamy i can
tell
we're gonna imagine it
did you do this on purpose
well this guy's uh already got a strong
stirring he might take the one of the
guest posts with him on the date uh the
grand prize of course is me if you guys
have a really good day you can go on a
whole date with with me
are you cheating on me
this is how i date now i just
invite
female comedians to watch other people
so they have to sit by you for two hours
i've never been to a girl he's like it's
nice because we don't have to make eye
contact
all right
are you guys ready to get this show
we started got some gays in here
surprising
doesn't usually happen probably a
comedian making a joke
so we're gonna pick a man
can you say that
man
and then we're going to pick a little
lady or a big lady or a normal
not going to have a size shape so the
first two dates on the show of other
people is josiah jackson
with mira
here he comes from the back
famed photographer
making his way to the front and mira you
want to go over there
over there
she's a little shy encouragement
are you guys ready
[Applause]
don't worry this is only being streamed
on youtube
live with 1 million viewers
[Applause]
you guys are gonna go on a little thing
for a minute and go ahead and let the
sparks fly
hello
nice to meet you
i am
[Music]
nice
the comedy music
headshots fashion
nice good
cool
so you are
25 24.
that's nice definitely way older
let's not go there yet
what a wonderful day
[Music]
how you felt and what your general
impressions were you seem very shy and
very reluctant um she's a pharmacist
she's got that drug money yeah
you want some drugs mira is your woman
very specific
how did you uh are you single mira or is
this uh are you cheating on someone
right now
how's this working for you
nice
uh did you think that josiah was a very
gentlemanly and sort of kind and yeah
very very
very nice man i think
very tall nice man
uh you're you're from cleveland
and then the conversation sort of died
right there
[Music]
that's my suggestion is go with the
fanciful lie um or where are you from
josiah
[Music]
nice
so you're a native what do you think
about all these people moving here you
want to be ours
what's the person from cleveland what
you
yeah i think here eight years ago so i
came before the rush before it was cold
and that was migration so when someone
josiah was in high school
[Music]
have you been to houston yeah
um
you guys uh could have also asked for a
lifeline we do this thing where there's
a lifeline there's 86 questions that i
found on this
website you got some of these things on
us what is your
what is your favorite animal
a dog
dan's best friend good answer mira is
that also your answer
nice you need the answer i like it
you guys do you guys have any um
things that are like crucial that you
look for in a partner
how do you feel about that mira you you
seem like you could flip a switch
i was gonna say mood stability
was important
oh we're getting closer than we think
that's awesome you guys both like
reliable
uh predictable
even if it's bad as long as you're not
bouncing up and down yeah
that's cool unless it's in the bedroom
that was a bouncing up and down joke not
a bipolar joke
i'm only bipolar in the bedroom
double-sided dildos
josiah you're from here what is your
favorite place to take a date in austin
texas
it depends on the vibe that i get from
them usually if it's
like if she has like something like she
has a frog in her pocket then i'll take
her to [ __ ] uh
a pool table or something
or something outdoorsy like that's the
thing yeah will you please define frogs
[Music]
are you happy to see me or is that just
a frog in your car
see like outdoorsy stuff in that pool
oh yeah i mean
i can go anywhere you know what i'm
saying but that's a little bipolar
uh mira do you have a favorite spot in
your eight years of austin experience
creek in the cave maybe
yeah like comedy show
green belt yeah
that's awesome you guys can chill in the
river together and sit there frogs
where would you take her where would you
take me
japanese barbecue spot easy
and you also have asian written on your
shirt this guy's a chaser i think it
says water i don't know
i don't know what the top symbol is but
the middle symbol is middle and the
bottom symbol is small miranda can you
uh back me up on this
not my language
but yeah i mean um a lot of chinese uh
crossover in uh korean culture so you
know maybe you guys could find a lot of
commonalities together
because you appreciate our culture
apparently what's your favorite episode
of dragon ball z
never seen it
you just wear the asian so what what
part of asia do you like
what what about us is it that you
appreciate
why i would probably say like the
southern area probably the philippines
that area
i mean
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
what part of asia do you like you've
been to the philippines no no we just
like the idea of it
yeah the jungles
that's right no i don't mean to
disparage your love of our continent
it's a big continent
i think we need to flip this
where would you take josiah on a date if
you were wearing the pants
[Music]
um
do you like to go on dates with friends
does that make you feel like you get to
know each
other yeah i mean it's a good hang it's
like good to go with a group of people
everyone's drunk
uh yeah i mean you guys seem like
my dad's drunk
[Music]
that's my
strategy my go-to
uh but yeah you guys uh
seemed like you guys would go along well
together you guys both seemed quiet
did you guys go on a second date
yeah
the pause was a little suspicious
where was your hesitation coming from i
didn't want to sound overzealous i
didn't want to sound rude either so i
just
yeah you have a filipino friend yes
what about you
look at that fresh skin
he's such a
baby a little little child
how old are you
i'm just saying even being 25
[Music]
how long is your dick
what is the circumference of your
interest
uh it's just a really personal question
i guess
some women don't like to reveal that um
but yeah thank you guys so much for
coming on this
i think that
josiah
very intense and
you know my favorite one was the asian
bbq obviously she's like
our next date is with rebecca and cody
mears
[Applause]
they're dating with friends
nice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi
um
all right that's it we're gonna go do
pointers now
and time you know this lovely couple
pointing at each other in a non-sexual
way
i kind of like their chemistry
yeah
i like that we got straight to the moon
did you accept your answer cody
i feel like it's always my first day
question at this point i just want to
get right to it so
just any opinion at all honestly
you know what is your opinion
i think it's all [ __ ] i think
everything is [ __ ]
but it also respects women's opinions
you know
you're coming in with a backward
baseball cap
american flag on your shirt asking about
the moon
you're definitely fitting a stereotype
where were you on january 6th
my car broke down otherwise it probably
would have been
it seems like fun honestly i think we
had a blast
but
conspiracy theories are always fun uh
it's like oh are you like with the
status quo are you like sort of on the
outside so you're like what did you say
what your job was do you have a
pharmacist
just handing out drugs
[Music]
too
uh
[Music]
you guys were having a great
conversation social media game is
lacking apparently
um
is it because you post stories or
because you don't post
i mean it's not for everyone
[Music]
[Music]
what do you do for a living
me yeah i just do comedy i live in a van
anyways back to
he's like an cody
uh you know like he doesn't follow him
yeah
um
[Music]
he goes
[Music]
so what is like something that you look
for in a date like when you first get a
date what is one of the first things
um
i don't know i guess
like just first impression i guess
their shoes
shoes did you look at cody's i did not
use
what would you guess his shoes are i
feel like he's wearing cowboy boots
[Music]
how did it go and who was it
i was a girl back home probably in july
and uh it was all right we went to good
ice cream and we ended up talking like
three and a half hours
lately i wish that would be more
interesting
what's
what did you guys talk about uh she
talked about work for a lot
quite a lot
yeah
rebecca do you find yourself tending to
take work home with you
i'm not talking about your pill
addiction
[Music]
uh yes and no i mean
it is
i work in a non-traditional pharmacy so
it's not like you go fill and then leave
so you're like
a non-traditional pharmacy is just
further proving the point that we think
you sell drugs
[Music]
but it's not traditional yeah me too i
shall read if anybody needs to talk
about the end of the show
are you ever like oh no i gave mr
rosenbaum like the arthritis medicine
and he wanted my eggers don't get her
fired
[Music]
but i don't really feel anymore so um
yeah but
yeah that happens a lot in pharmacy
though again um
oh so the bottle can be honest but the
pills inside could be wrong yes it
reminds me a lot of dating in 2020 yeah
it's very deceiving a very similar setup
that explains by crippling meth
[Music]
traditional
addiction
they're like this says one thing on the
outside but on the inside it's not
traditional
no i'm sure it's a great non-traditional
you bring your work home with you
i mean i live in my car so i kind of
work in my car
[Music]
so you work for uber eats your favorite
door national sofias
[Music]
what do you look for in a man
[Music]
yeah uh i like tall men that are
athletic and
have
you know some goals
in life
[Music]
what about short men that live in their
cars
i'd be friends with them yeah that's
awesome you got a friend now cody
[Music]
he's a very josiah man yeah maybe you
guys could do a couple swab with mira
so we could look forward to a woman and
i don't
feel that it's fair that we ask
probably someone that can uh
wants me to be the best person i want to
be but also reciprocates that and wants
me to help them do this
that was a really good answer
did you like that answer rebecca that
was a good answer yes so thoughtful very
stable emotionally too
merely
not financially but emotionally i don't
know
[Music]
i mean i live in a car too so i'm
just but um i mean uh so uh how long
have you lived in austin
rebecca
um
almost three years now yeah and uh how
have you found the dating scene to be
like in
um
i haven't really dated a lot uh because
i was in a relationship for a lot of it
yeah but i hear it's rough
what is the
from
[Music]
is
[Music]
moon landing
so what are some of the
horrible things that you've heard are
the rough things that have happened in
uh the awesome days well or just your
worst date some of my
i friends i've got stories there's some
yeah
i don't know if they don't want to share
though they're like
just use citizenship okay i'm trying to
think of like
my one friend she like goes on date
after date of page she's actually dating
someone now but
um
this one guy
she uh he was he was not stable like
mood wise like they went out to dinner
or something and he was just
uh
he didn't really appreciate him in
general like he kept telling her
uh you know no like if we get in a
relationship or whatever like i would
want you to stay home with the kids and
just like very
um
offensive things like on a first date
like really late in the author and
demanding yeah he was just crazy there's
definitely more i just can't think about
at this moment would you be okay
that she dated
for like more than a minute he was a
recovering drug addict which cool um and
like she had just gone home to like
meet his family or whatever and then
coming back from that same weekend on
monday he like called her frantically
and was like oh like i i need to go back
to rehab like you know i can't be with
you i can't have a relationship right
now whatever all this stuff and it's
like saying you know he's using me again
or whatever and she's like oh okay and
then she finds out like a week later
he's still he's supposed to go back to
utah he's like still in austin and he
did not go anywhere and his family has
no idea that they even like broke up
because like uh
his sister reached out to her and was
like oh
love love meeting you you guys should
come back or whatever and my friend was
like uh i think he's in rehab and they
were like not aware of it at all but i
feel like that was kind of like
he's psychotic really quick like under
the rug you know he needs family and
then you don't rehab well cody is
famously not that uh you know addicted
to anything besides living in his car
yeah very true cody how do you feel
about women staying at home with the
children personally i don't want
children so that'll be you know
you know
i like that
but if she wants to though
what if it's someone else's children she
just wants to stay home yeah what if you
met someone who had children already
he's open to
that situation what a gentleman
this yeah you guys are really chill
vibes
and i hope you guys go on a second date
yeah you guys both have glasses similar
eyes
i thought about the love spark right off
the bat
[Music]
i would go like as friends
maybe if you guys find out what your
opinions on 911
let's try the
lgbtqia plus bucket
we got
tonka
going with
pedro valenzuela a man
wait do you want to go on a date with a
woman and a man
all right thanks sorry about that but
you're going on a date with the dude
uh here we go everything is on the line
you have the ability to flip a woman the
pizza is happy
so yeah we don't even have to yeah
[Music]
her yeah okay all right
what do you go by
uh
sometimes my dad calls me bendel
sometimes i just go by skate
a little more
you want to use the
upper throat
okay what are we learning here
not much
i just moved here like six months ago
uh michigan
welcome thank you thanks
feel very welcome
um you have really pretty eyes oh thanks
very i like your face
mistake number one but he has nice eyes
and it has fresh peppers that's kind of
hot
yeah
like that spark i was feeling earlier
right i did feel bad
a little bit of a spark i think that's
fine
i think that's where i was very pizza
related
did you feel a spark uh sure yeah
that is not true
like if a guy's like was it good for you
and you're like sure
well at least
a very uh unregrettable experience so
far yeah that's how you know it's a good
day just kind of hoping for a guy i'm
not gonna lie
me too
[Laughter]
uh so you guys uh
you guys look sad i'm just trying to get
this
uh thank you guys so much for coming on
this date is it done already
thank you so much for going on this day
what do you guys think about uh
moving here he's from michigan
where are you from san antonio thank you
for asking oh so you're a texan
yes
nice
what's your ethnicity
half hispanic half white oh you are
hispanic okay so you understood yes
[Music]
or austin texas austin texas what makes
austin better than san antonio so many
things
do you want the pizza
i'm reading the side of the box because
i'm wondering if you were to compare
this date to that numbers
what's your favorite pizza topping
cheese pedro
uh pepperoni problem so we're both
pretty basic would you
would you pick up the pepperonis
and then feed them
definitely
that was weird
lgbtq days
maybe in the trampoline
one of them we're like
are you gay they're like we don't really
know
i think we changed our minds yeah maybe
no let's be straight let's make our
parents happy i still like women but no
i like guys too
i feel like pedro is going to i'll do
whatever you want me
i don't play the lotto so i don't really
think accurate um
[Music]
would you like that like would you are
you asking me to blow her is that what
you're just doing
i think we have a very selective hearing
right now
where you blow your hair out right no i
actually really dig the hairs oh thank
you
spark
[Music]
um
typically
i live at the park so i'm just like
in a car
it's in a car
[Applause]
the pizza came
[Music]
i've never met so many people that live
in the car
welcome to the community
josiah actually lives indoors
[Music]
a human being but uh what uh what how
does that make you feel uh someone that
lives in a car
uh is that a is that a deal breaker or
is that sort of intriguing
i have many questions
[Music]
also shame there sometimes i try not to
though because it seems weird
never worked out there
[Music]
[Applause]
showers mostly
it's not a gym membership it's a shower
membership
i just try to maintain a regular like
bowel schedule
you know
movements during the day
uh no that's never too late for
pepperoni
if you're feeding them to me but uh
bowel movements
um
i said that already but it's [ __ ]
you know i do that during the day so
that i don't have to [ __ ] at night if i
do have to chill at night then i just go
to bed
[Music]
situation um but yeah i mean bowel
movements are very difficult in a mobile
situation
you know
it's kind of like a gatorade bottle
you know what i'm saying you try to use
[Music]
saying
a gatorade bottle is wide enough you
know so you don't have to eat or as much
obviously
but he's bigger than a coke bottle
that's smaller than a gatorade
which is probably every man have you
ever accidentally drank
no that's never happened
are you worried it will
no
it happened
all right pedro and tanta thank you guys
so much and uh
hopefully
that lone star is full of stuff
i would not adventure
a sip of that but thank you so much for
the little caesars the handshake of love
right there they walk away we got
another straight couple after the lgbtq
couple
who was also the most straightforward
there was actually penetration involved
in that day
jeremiah price and aliyah
aliyah
jeremiah
i know him personally aaliyah i just met
tonight
let's see the sparks fly with jeremiah
price and aaliyah
right here
hello
do you have any jeremiah
so the pets i have are family pets
actually
i have a malty poo named panini
and then i have a
um a german shepherd named pepper
but some people are asking like are you
a cat or a dog person i just say boys
nice
do you like cats i do like cats
um
they don't like me
they like
yeah it's a pretty dope
so what do you want to be when you grow
up like
[Music]
so my dream is to open up yes let's go
my dream is to open a cat cafe yeah cafe
[Music]
and time
thank you guys so much for going on this
one-minute date
live on stage
uh so you work at a austin pets alive
that's
that's kind of on the nose it's like is
there an austin pets not alive
that's awesome you uh you work with
animals and uh
what what specifically do you do at the
uh is it an animal shelter
yeah it's an animal shelter um
so i work in the cat team some are on
cats all the time my title is cat care
specialist so
cat care i'm basically like a cat nurse
so i attended all the cats meetings and
give them medication and fluids all that
kind of stuff that's awesome a lot of uh
autistic people have been compared to
cats so i'm sure you're doing very well
in the awesome dating scene
and uh
jeremiah
you said you're into lighters i am the
laggers
you are you're delighted by the tigers
yes they're pretty cool i was a little
suspect though um what's your usual
dating age range because you asked her
when she wanted to be when she grew up
oh man um
well
legal for sure
but um
he loves legality
[Music]
the last the last lady i went out with
was
38 actually
i'm 24. oh you're a baby dude
you guys can uh you know get face
tattoos and get supreme
what about asian guys
anyways
were you excited when you like saw like
that you guys were lining up and you
were coming
[Music]
that's your job now our dream job is cat
cat favorite jeremiah what is your dream
job i love to be a game show host
actually
all right let's stand back you got real
wayne brady vibes
whose line is it anyway i'm close
close great smiling happy man you gotta
already be famous to be a game show host
so you gotta have a lot of catching up
to do so let's play an improv game
pretend you guys are both at the airport
and
you see a a liger in a cage and you guys
are an old married couple
and see
go ahead you're you're there that's
where you are yeah get the shade
comfortable oh there's a legend oh you
see that lighter over here yeah i
remember when you were young you wanted
anybody
remember why i wanted the battle
but you said no
yes
we're already old [ __ ] it
uh
stage work there because we're really
digging into each other about past
grievances
what i liked about that is that we could
see a future with you guys you know
it was old and kind of sad but we saw
that
you guys have very similar vibes uh very
chill
what what do you like to do when that
makes you the most chill do you like to
listen to the lo-fi playlist on spotify
yeah i listen to it sometimes um i'm a
classical pianist so i'll play whoa
can you play something for us
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
beautiful beautiful thing just head on
over and do your thing i'll let you know
[Music]
he knows songs
here we go with jeremiah tickling the
ivories and here you're
okay and take it away
[Music]
it's a little
depressing
[Music]
nicer
[Music]
[Applause]
is does that show a deeper side
yeah i mean i'm a cello player
bring out the
[Music]
that cello beautiful man how did you uh
have you ever played piano for a woman
and like
she's just been so odd that she just
like married you or like dated
or
went up to him and played the cello
right now
have you ever been
[Music]
yeah i was playing
um on a public piano
and um
she was like wow that's amazing and i'm
like yeah i can teach you she's like
well you're off key but here let me show
you when she slides in she plays the
same exact song i was playing
a hundred times better
people started gathering around and
throwing money at her and i just left
it was pretty sad i don't know how you
could be off-key on a piano you just
have to press a button
for that so whoa
i put my hair though so it takes me like
three weeks to win a song
only taking
so
where would you guys go
on a second date
jeremiah you give your most ideal option
and then you give yours i like
stargazing
that's the big dipper that's the cup
would you bring a blanket or you're just
gonna lay her down in the grass have you
ever done this before you pointed a
laser pointer at a star and you can see
it in the sky
oh yeah you can see the laser in the sky
you can like trace out i guess you're
gonna feel
this yeah
it's illegal
yeah they might hit a plane but i mean
uh stars are pretty far away i don't
know if the laser is going to hit it you
get like the general
oh okay i i've never heard of that
that's [ __ ] awesome thanks for
telling me that
uh
leah
what is uh your answer to where where
would you take uh
jeremiah
just rolled to jamie
jesus
senator what positions i'd say probably
now
have you heard of trans-siberian
orchestra
[Music]
we would probably be the only non-white
people there
when are they coming in
second date would you also would you go
scarce stargazing
yeah you can listen to the music point a
laser pointer up at the stars pointed
out the your favorite musician i like
this line
[Music]
but uh thank you guys so much
[Applause]
party have a good time yeah we'll make
some symphony plans
give birth to a violin player later
give it up for jeremiah
[Applause]
we got uh three three women left in the
bucket so let's try to get through all
these women trying to get them matched
up with the thirsty dude
right now we got colin o'meara going on
who's already on a date
[Music]
[Music]
yeah are you guys together or this is
the first day i hope this is the first
day and that's like the second date oh
that was the first so first one went
well this is the second one right yeah
this is pretty good wow
[Music]
what did you say
you said you talk about your interests
um i love soccer i mean i used to play
when i was younger do you like watch
like the premier league and all that
[ __ ]
what's your club what are your support
chelsea okay uh christian holstein on
chelsea's from uh closer on from here i
don't know yeah like my buddies were
playing on travel cycle all the time and
everything yeah
um and uh there's a guy on manchester
united who went to my high school
um yeah zack steffen i think it's his
name it's a goalie i played soccer at
the y
for a few years
[Applause]
i know some famous people you grew up
around a lot of soccer players
too
i mean i didn't eat the
christina
that's uh that is our city that we live
in
what an amazing coincidence you love
soccer call it amira plays with balls
you know
[Music]
no i'm just kidding you are you are one
right now with colin amira uh
so
how does it feel to be on a date with
someone who's on a date with someone
else
you're kind of like and she's the man
right now
yeah it's kind of like an inception or
something you know like i'm
[Laughter]
i think it'd be funny too it's like if
you guys got married
and then
where did you go on your second date oh
i just went on a date with another man
are you either of you guys in
like we've got a the threesomes
sign
growing right now
i'm a christian
a bad one um
are you a christian no i don't i'm not
religious so i'm not really that
religious
okay
thank you
i will ask the majority
[Music]
which one's your favorite
i mean
yeah let's get into it dude
yeah did you bring the [ __ ]
monotheism on your first date
no that's awesome uh polytheism you know
i uh you know like all the saints in
catholicism
the patron saints lost causes
so like if you had to call upon one of
one of your uh
hindu gods right now which one would you
think is the most apt
for this situation only hans would is
this in your list of questions
what's your favorite pet next one if you
have a
[Music]
[Music]
staple in hinduism because
she's just like she's a tiger and she's
got all these weapons
so she's she's pretty badass she didn't
like her like
a lot of guys
she rides around in a tight she's like a
badass like amazon
you can say that yeah
she's
like very empowering and just like
yeah there's a whole like nine-day
festival for her and
all that kind of stuff
i feel like a good first date question
would be
ideally on like a night out with each
other would you rather like
stay in and watch a movie or would you
rather like
go out
in like a bar or do you know like what's
your ideal of like a good hay
is it a first date or is it like you
just know you you're about four or five
eight you know each other this is your
your day-to-day date yeah this is like a
fish new day
[Music]
but after that yeah why not take it
inside watch
quite literally actually do you live in
a home yeah
[Music]
[Music]
do you like going on dates with like
indian men do you find that different
than uh all these hockeys
i have i don't really have a preference
um
i've been on dates with different people
um
yeah i went to college in dallas so
that's much different than
a lot of um whites a lot of african
americans
not many white guys
so
like would you like dating wise god gave
his answer what would you feel is like
you're your best average
um
i
i love
going hiking i mean i was born and
raised in austin so it's kind of kind of
into
like my childhood
but i i do like going out but if it's
like further on like the fourth
date or whatever just staying back maybe
cooking something together or whatever
cooking together
[Music]
um
and then i've recently discovered
chicken as well
using that um uh put like salt and then
pepper garlic powder paprika and then uh
chili powder and then you know put down
the airfryer yeah sounds like the pizza
that pedro
has just
how old are you i'm 22 22.
23. okay
this bucket has a will of its own yeah
we don't want to you know commit any
crimes on this show that's going on on
youtube
um
i was a christian oh that's a [ __ ]
answer
you just said i'm non-religious right
now yeah but you said
um
[Applause]
[Music]
is pretty much like a giant gangbang
right they're all the same
so that's why we invited you all here
[Music]
is she the one that's like i did a
report
like in like fifth grade about the
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like world cultures it was so amazing
because we were like the token three
indians
so it was fun
what do you guys will do for a living
now
um well i i do comedy but to pay bills i
had to work at a moving company
it helped have multiple arms that's true
yeah i wish i was vishnu
yeah channel you know get some tips
on the hinduism
channel hint channel the monkey whatever
[Applause]
um
like
the administration side of like
hospitals so like you're the one to make
you're like we're out of gauze and
you're like i'm [ __ ] honest yeah um
i'm like we're on the staffing side so
recruiting nurses and hiring and doing
hr are you scared to hire like new
nurses and doctors after everyone
graduated from
online um no actually i have a couple
friends that are in medical school right
now but um it's really cool to put them
in the training program and they go
through residencies and stuff right yeah
but you can [ __ ] that right
you like grey's anatomy
um
i guess i mean sometimes my friends just
put it on
[Music]
this guy watches the news apparently
[Music]
did you like the uh
december right his birthday's november
did you like the uh uh robert downey jr
sherlock holmes movies oh yeah i love
working today too yeah you think marvel
fans do i'm guessing people i i really
enjoy movies but um i'm really into
bollywood movies
yeah and just like boring movies as well
i've seen a bible movie once at uh the
bartender's
[Music]
have you seen about time
yeah that sounds familiar isn't that
rachel yeah it does have original games
it's on netflix and understand movies my
first date with me actually
you guys think you'll ever watch it
together how do you guys would you guys
go on a second date pretend he's not in
the room
yeah would you go on a second date with
kyle and conan would you go on a certain
date with reyna
we're the guy that you're originally
here with
a lot of things could really improve
this day but thank you guys so much for
doing it publicly
[Applause]
let's try to get these two up here we
got
molly
going on a date with
nicholas
[Music]
[Music]
let's go
hi
hi how are you i'm okay how are you good
welcome to our first date
yeah i killed jessica robert for that
okay kind of into it cool
i like going down to the lake the lake
which like yeah the one right here
i just moved it three weeks ago you know
i have no breakfast oh i also don't know
anything i moved it two months ago
but i i feel like it's a river when
people call it a lake so
it's like a big body of water is it like
a stream that goes through
have you not actually seen it no
well you didn't give me a direct answer
if you think it's a lake but some people
call it river so i was trying to clarify
uh it looks kind of like a river
a wide river
so it's a river
yeah i think so when they call it
okay
i
okay
[Applause]
he's been in austin about two minutes
from what i can gather yeah remember the
river is a pretty big deal in austin
yeah uh but it is sort of a lake
it's a damned river yeah you live right
by it though apparently
you had to cross
yeah i would consider that a river
yeah that's why he was so confused
because he agrees with your river logic
he couldn't grab his mind around the
lake yeah i was like okay we're good all
right
nicholas starting out with a joke about
murder which i always find to be
difficult
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
did you get the jessica rabbit reference
i know who that is
not a real person
so it's not real murder like just to be
quick just be clear isn't it
[Music]
[Music]
so you just moved to austin yes what
about you guys here
i'm sorry
do you live in a home
yes i love your apartment
do you live in a home
[Music]
okay so
it's cool
like santa is that number i'm not
but my sister is
[Applause]
why don't they all say that
because i don't want the other one to be
funny
an ego thing
yeah probably insecurities more so
so what if she's funny that's cool as
long as she's not doing it on stage
you mean ghost rider now i'm like yeah
i'm gonna go do
stand up
a jealous comedian
nothing better
nothing better than that
you should go on a date with a laugh
track
um so
what is your sister's did she do comedy
in austin or no
where
uh what's chicago now l.a
oh is she uh
famous no
i've gone to like so many shows where
there's like eight people in the crowd
yeah
uh what uh what's her name
um
[Applause]
online right now
so what kind of cell humor are you in
and what kind of style humor do you
think i want to know what you do
do you like dry silly dark one miners
can you give us one right now
he's like uh i think muhammad ali's
great boxer of alzheimer's
i mean is it sultan one of our great
heroes
[Music]
are you a huge sports fan do you love
sports i do actually thanks for asking
what's your favorite sports thing
but when it comes to sports he's like
which one of those things do you like
the most
do you love the court or the field or
the pitch
[Music]
are you from chicago as well
uh no oh so who's your who's your
football football team
minnesota
[Music]
[Music]
or sport i enjoy watching soccer and
basketball football you go you go to the
bar
watch the game drink a beer kind of eye
yeah if it's on i'll watch it but mainly
like my friends get together and they
watch they watch them all the time so
i'll go hang out with them and just
watch well i'm noticing you're drinking
the water do you like to drink uh
sometimes yeah
i had a beer
improv
earlier
you guys are both in
minneapolis minnesota where the vikings
play
yes okay
in uh viking stadium
you guys are
i've been in a relationship three years
uh
the your team's on the gridiron they're
uh
throwing the uh the pigskin up and down
and uh nicholas he's not really into it
but he's trying he's trying to like
participate in the thing that you love
so much football and you're like trying
to ignore the offensive things that he's
saying about how little he knows about
football and go do it
number 23 has the ball now
i don't know who number 23 is but do you
like justin jefferson sure
okay
why do you like it though
his name
it's a double j name it's easy to
pronounce that's right
what about the coach do you like the
coach which one's that see the one
wearing the striped shirt
yeah
he's getting some pretty bad calls right
now okay
what about the other team who are we
playing i can't remember
um
years i don't know
the raiders oh okay
yeah is that true are we playing them
yes okay that is all right aren't you so
proud of me that i'm paying attention
babe yeah you're having a lot of fun oh
so much fun yeah it's kind of cold isn't
it we're in minnesota
it's true but you know what we're in
like a closed building
i think so yeah my hair mess yeah why
don't you remind me to bring them
because i'm not your mom
for like 10
star player years he gets alzheimer's
he says do you like dating women that
remind you of your mom
wrong answer
nicholas and
his
thank you guys so much for coming
molly sure
[Music]
exchange contact information and let us
know how it goes on our uh instagram
otherpeoplecomedy.com
and uh we'll post your success story
about five years from now when you're in
minneapolis perfect freezing your ass
off in the indoor stadium
i promise to remember my mittens
[Applause]
a dude a bunch of dudes
we got a dude named shaman
[Applause]
we got a comedian holly johnstone
women that haven't been on dates yet in
the front
we only got five minutes
[Applause]
[Music]
a little chair pull a very gentlemanly
move that hopefully reyna will
experience later
and
what's your name
yeah we're filtering them all out aren't
we
here we go
okay so we bulk in here with other
people tonight so
hershey hi hi
what's up
what's been the highlight of every day
so far
yes
it's gonna sound really lame but reading
my book oh no way
like fiction yeah
but it's not fiction but more of like
just all around
how long have you been like all about
like reading it's like a
similar thing like you enjoy it or just
how long they've been all about reading
yeah
since i learned to read
[Music]
okay what book has like probably not
like the biggest impact for you it's
called the little life
have you heard of it
it's really devastating but it's good
devastating
and time
a sad story
you guys are talking about reading uh
one of my favorite things to do next to
writing
one of the basic skills um
book a week that's a lot of books i
tried 52 books a year yeah yeah do you
own the library card or you just
as a stockholder
what's the last book you read i rewrite
risk for that great book by the way
oh
can i read that will you read a little
like
so
you guys you're both here with other
people are you here on a date are you
here with friends i am on a date i won't
we know that
i'm on a date and with a friend oh
roommate
so you brought your roommate on a date
closer to your roommate than you are i
thought that was just a random guy in
the crowd
that you sometimes leaned over and
talked to
that's my boyfriend christopher
have
[Music]
other people
peer pressure
yeah yeah definitely don't lie it wasn't
so you signed up when you walked in the
door
you know what this is gonna be fun we're
like let's just go for it
yeah that's the spirit of the show thank
you guys so much for coming out
unfortunately we have to cut it short uh
because that's the end of the show uh
but give it up for our last
[Applause]
date second date after your dates
tonight you want to meet up well we'll
need to discuss the books it's like a
book club
platonic
god i've never seen a friend zone
give it up for
[Applause]
[Music]
you here tomorrow night called
punchlines where two teams go
head-to-head and the winning teams will
get their own feature spot on our late
night show here on thursday night they
make happy hour all night uh you can get
your tickets at creighton.com
thank you guys so much
[Music]
uh you can check us out at other people
comedy on instagram thank you guys so
much for coming out uh tippy bar snap
drive safe thank you guys so much
[Applause]
[Music]
all righty thank you so much for coming
this evening folks we now compare our
showroom for the next show we do have
our bar in that patty a bit for you to
hang out thanks for joining us
[Music]
[Music]